[Music]
the eternals are one of marvel's
strangest groups and thena is one of
their most fascinating members a scholar
a warrior and an immortal her life spans
eons we're here to explain her entire
story from her ancient origins to her
unique relationship to greek myth
the eternals are an immortal race of
super beings created through experiments
on early humans those experiments were
conducted by a group of ultra powerful
pseudo-deities known as the celestials
some of the first creatures to ever
exist in the marvel universe the
universe itself called the first
firmament created a group of servants
this group soon split into two the
aspirants and the celestials the
aspirants were loyal servants who wished
for nothing more than to serve the
celestials deviated from the first
firmament's plan wanting to create lives
of their own this led to a civil war
between the inhabitants of the cosmos in
the end the celestials triumphed the
first firmament and its aspirants beat a
hasty retreat into other fragmented
universes leaving the celestials to
tinker with the marvel universe as they
pleased
the celestials landed on earth eons ago
and set to experimenting upon early
humanity what resulted were two offshoot
groups the uniformly beautiful and
enormously powerful eternals and the
dramatically mutated deviants the
deviant's resentment of humanity led to
an adversarial relationship with earth's
inhabitants while their mutation allowed
them to build an advanced civilization
in record time in short order the
deviants built a vast and cruel empire
at the same time the eternals voted to
remove themselves from humanity building
isolated cities away from the rest of
the world we were instructed not to
interfere in any human conflicts unless
deviants are involved
both of these outcomes displeased the
celestials who flooded the earth upon
their return athena the daughter of
eternals leader zuris who was born as
azura around this time in the city of
olympia though she's thousands of years
old she's considered quite young
compared to many of her immortal
brethren
jack kirby created the eternals with
ancient greek myths in mind icarus
became vigorous the god of the forge
hephaestus became fastos the goddess
cersei became cersei to be clear the
eternals are in most cases not the gods
they are mistaken for most of those gods
actually exist in the marvel universe
one exception is that cersei appears to
really be the mythical cersei generally
speaking though the eternals are
frequently confused for their olympian
counterparts the eternal known as the
forgotten one was often mistaken for
hercules who he's actually been buddies
with since ancient greece it follows
then that athena daughter of an immortal
named zurus who let a city called
olympia was mixed up with the goddess
athena daughter of zeus
centuries ago the greek gods decided to
put down roots only to find the eternals
already established in olympia the two
groups met and noticed the striking
resemblance a deal was struck in which
the eternals would act as the greek
pantheon's representatives on earth they
would visit with humanity in the gods
stead leaving the deities to their
pocket dimension of mount olympus to
seal the deal zurus decreed that his
daughter's name would change from azura
to athena she came to be worshipped as
athena goddess of wisdom war and
handicraft she even inspired the
construction of the city of athens the
name stuck with her and she's continued
to use it
theanum might not be as much of a
died-in-the-wool pacifist as fastos but
she does view the fighting between the
eternals and the deviants to be
essentially pointless that viewpoint
only grew stronger when she met and fell
for a deviant named chrome crow and
athena met in ancient babylon where
crowe had an opportunity to slay thena
he refused love grew between the two but
crowe and thena knew to keep their
relationship secret their partnership is
known to few even as it carried on for
thousands of years they eventually had
children together after reigniting their
relationship during the vietnam war
using her eternal powers thena implanted
the resulting twin children in a human
woman to continue to keep their
relationship secret they were born as
deborah and donald ritter seemingly
ordinary humans as eternal deviant
hybrids they were anything but
having to keep up appearances of
fighting an eternal war while secretly
being in love with your supposed enemy
takes its toll at times crowe's actions
brought theena and crowe into direct
conflict crowe attacked new york city
leading bands of deviants through the
city streets zuris knew that he would
have to fight the deviants yet again and
sent his daughter to help put down the
deviant uprising though athena was
ultimately successful in stopping the
deviant attack crow still believed he
accomplished his goals the deviants
deeply hated the celestials after years
of being treated as second-class beings
they believed that their attacks would
inspire a widespread hatred of anything
from outer space feeling that he had
done what he set out to crowe accepted a
truce with the eternals
when the celestials came to earth once
again the leader of the eternals made a
shocking decision he attacked them zurus
believed the celestials would destroy
all of humanity if they found earth
lacking all of the world's semi-immortal
beings including the asgardians worked
to turn back the celestials for their
own reasons when the eternals formed the
unimined emerging of their consciousness
with zuris at the center it left the
leader particularly vulnerable when the
celestial struck the unimined with a
powerful bolt of energy zuris was killed
athena assumed command as prime eternal
until she was forced to
abdicate icarus one of the most
hot-headed eternals never accepted dina
as the prime maternal and he carried
quite a bit of sway in olympia he
repeatedly challenged theena for her
throne and though icarus was
unsuccessful
thena struggled mightily with the
responsibility suddenly thrust upon her
she struggled with the idea that the
same fate that met her father might
await her and suffered beneath the
weight of being without her father for
the first time it also didn't help that
crow had placed a device on her that
very subtly manipulated her decision
making to favor the deviants athena was
dedicated to keeping her people safe but
her love for crow the influence of his
device and her general anxiety came to a
disastrous head when she attacked icarus
to save crow from certain death icarus
took the opening defeated theena and
took over as prime eternal
thino was one of the many eternals who
had their memory wiped when the eternal
sprite manipulated reality totally
ignorant of her past and powers athena
lived life as a human researcher working
for stark enterprises she was knocked
out of her mortal reverie by icarus who
had broken sprite's spell and needed the
help of the remaining eternals to stop
another celestial plot while living as a
human named ike harris icarus had been
captured and vaporized by deviants when
his body reformed in the eternal's
abandoned city of olympia he realizes
that all of the eternals were suffering
a similar case of memory loss we need to
find the others athena and icarus
traveled around the world to find their
former companions all living as everyday
humans and eventually stop the emergence
of a sleeping celestial living
underneath los angeles after their
victory thena decided to live alongside
the human son she'd had in the interim
over the objections of her fellow
eternals
after millennia of life athena died
alongside all the other eternals in a
2018 avengers story a group known as the
dark celestials attacked earth while the
bodies of regular celestials began to
rain down upon the planet tony stark
traveled to olympia to check on the
celestial's most famous experiments and
found the dead bodies of the eternals in
a dying monologue icarus explained that
the eternals weren't sent to earth to
protect humanity at the beginning of the
attack they learned that they were
placed on earth to cultivate humanity as
a viral weapon icarus tells iron man we
are alive tony stark we eternals were
great fools we weren't here to protect
you we were
to cultivate you your virulence to them
to the space gods you
are a useful pathogen
this knowledge drove the eternals mad as
icarus lamented they couldn't handle
learning the truth and it destroyed them
of course this comic so all the eternals
including theena came back to life in
the 2021 eternal series
the eternals are one of marvel's more
obscure properties and yet an eternals
movie came to be meaning people around
the world will soon know all about
icarus cersei and all the rest of the
gang that includes theena who will be
played by angelina jolie one of the most
famous actresses on the planet hi
hello jolie has said she's committed to
bringing a realistic version of the
immortal warrior goddess to the silver
screen as she told usa today she's
explored everything from ballet to
swordsmanship in an effort to get the
graceful fighting of theena down she
said she's a warrior i'm going to have
to work very hard to give the marvel
cinematic universe the athena they
deserve
athena is a one-of-a-kind character who
deserves an actress of jolie's caliber
she might be soft-hearted enough to fall
for a deviant but so too is she a
legendary scholar warrior and leader
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite marvel characters are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]
you